all right we now have uh our latest
tears in my eyes story
from Infowars conspiracy theorist Alex
Jones and I want to play a couple of
different things for you one this is
very short but it's just to set the
stage of where Alex Jones currently is
and his sort of public discourse and
dialogue Alex Jones said yesterday that
Kerry lake is really the governor of
Arizona now this is not something that
there is debate you know when I was on
with Lex Friedman a couple weeks ago he
said this thing about how you know isn't
everything sort of an opinion at this
point and I said no it's really not it
is not up for debate whether Kerry lake
is the governor of Arizona a Katie Hobbs
received more votes in November of 2022
in that race Katie Hobbs was inaugurated
as the governor of Arizona and Katie
Hobbs is the governor of Arizona it's
not a matter of opinion but listen to
Alex Jones you can always trust him to
tell you the truth right we have to
continue to expose what's happened we
have to get Integrity in elections
there's total fraud Arizona's the
perfect example carry Lakes an
incredible champion of Freedom there
she's obviously really the governor the
person that ran the election I believe
stole the election
she's obviously really the governor
there is no way in which Carey lake is
really the governor and what I think is
really important about these sorts of
Clips is when people write to me and
they say you know Alex Jones was right
about this Alex Jones was right about
that he's the only one you can really
trust
these exact sorts of declarations they
say them so confidently with the total
sometimes it's it's arrogance and
sometimes it's condescension Kerry lake
is obviously really the governor how do
you not know that you there is no
way in which Carrie lake is the governor
now let's move on to the tears in my
eyes story Alex Jones now says when he
goes to Liberal areas in Austin Texas
which he admits it's where the good
restaurants are and listen that's true
that's true the good restaurants in
Austin are absolutely in the liberal
areas uh he says everybody comes up to
him now and says we were wrong you were
right about everything this is sort of
like they came up to me with tears in
their eyes and said sir you've been
treated so unfairly here's Alex Jones
version of that story with the pain of
being promised it not having privacy you
actually get a real gauge I go to the
most liberal areas of Austin now that I
avoided for years has some of the best
restaurants
without even security now wow and
literally I go in a restaurant and
almost everyone comes over and says
we're sorry we were wrong we know the
government's evil we know the country's
been hijacked I just took my wife out to
dinner with some friends last Thursday
ever almost there by in the restaurant
came over an Italian restaurant black
white hispanic old young then I walked
to the parking garage ran to three
groups of people and black white and
Hispanic every group said we love you
we're sorry they all shed it you should
think you were bad so what that shows me
is in the most leftist areas they're
even converting and there is a real
Global Awakening there is a Great
Awakening happening as the counter the
great race what's really funny is you
can't find evidence of this anywhere
like think for a second what it would
mean if all of a sudden the entirety of
liberal Progressive woke Austin Texas
was so overcome with the undeniable
truth of the things Alex Jones has been
saying that they now go up to him and
say you've converted me we were wrong in
fact think think about what Alex Jones
wants you to believe
before he needed Security in Liberal
areas because people would come up to
him and I guess threaten him or maybe
accost him or you know whatever
now the progressive left has become so
overcome and enamored with Alex Jones
for telling the truth about the evil
government that he no longer needs
security the liberals who used to pose a
physical threat to him requiring him to
have security now they come up and say
you were right about everything does
anyone believe these stories does anyone
believe these stories I certainly don't
if you do then please leave a comment
send an email I want to hear from you I
often have a much longer list of
non-fiction books that I'd like to read
than I actually have the time for and
that's when summaries of books can be
really useful our sponsor short form is
the platform that goes Way Beyond what
other book summary platforms do because
short form provides a clear and concise
overview of the book that you can read
or listen to in one sitting but you also
get a ton of other crucial context about
how the book fits into the broader topic
like for example I went through the
short form guide for an American
sickness it's a book by Elizabeth
Rosenthal about the financial incentives
that plague the U.S health care System
many of which we've talked about short
form perfectly sums up the book's key
points but then it goes further it looks
at the background on how rosenthal's
perspective fits into the larger debate
on American Health Care and this just
gives you a more complete and balanced
understanding of the book and that
that's what I love about short form
short form has every non-fiction genre
imaginable and they publish new book
guides every single week my audience can
try short form totally free and get 25
off a subscription if you'd like at
shortform.com Pacman the link is down
below